iniziare subito
quando decisi
dei miei amici di partecipare una festa
in maschera e il problema più grande è
sempre quello
qual è la maschera migliore quale e
minuti semplicemente una cosa un pirata
della gabbia di legno e quindi sono
tornato a casa ho preso una vecchia
prozia però trattarla con un tubo
dell'adesivo forma forma di legno è
venuto fuori questo è stato primo premio
abbiamo niente si fa festa a galla i
festini maschera e quando sono entrato
lì infatti a carnevale a strano certi
poi a vestire i modi più strani trucchi
persone mi vedevano fa wow
come fai qual è il trucco momento non
c'è trucco veramente una gamba di legno
e il trucco non c'era appunto perché
cinque anni fa un centro motociclistico
perso la gamba ma non incidendo quindi
sicuramente mi ha cambiato la vita
ma ad oggi non mi sento di dire che era
cambiata in peggio anzi voglio dire che
mi ha cambiata in meglio perché non so
se la questione il carattere ma la
persona o io non vedo in un imputazione
un problema un disagio una disabilità la
prima cosa che mi dicono è speciale
raffrontata al meglio grande ma io mi
sento se vengo da fermo una provincia
piccola provincia e mi sento niente di
speciale
sono un ragazzo normalissimo che ho
sulla mia voglia di vivere
oggi sono qui per parlarvi di quello che
è stato il mio percorso
da quell'incidente fino ad oggi quella
che è stata la mia vita e la mia
disabilità
ad oggi io sono un atleta della
nazionale italiani siti in bolle vi
parlerò di quei traguardi che ho
raggiunto insieme io e la protesi io in
questi cinque anni sono riuscito a far
parte della nazionale italiana i fitti
invoglia a partecipare al primo
campionato europeo della nazionale di
siti in valle italiana sono riuscito a
laurearmi con in igiene dentale alla
facoltà di medicina
quindi ancora ho partecipato al secondo
europeo nel 2017 in croazia dove abbiamo
vinto abbiamo fatto la prima ha avuto la
prima vittoria storica dell'italia non
competizione internazionale
sono stato in corea del sud per le
qualificazioni ai campionati mondiali
che non è andato bene purtroppo però ci
arriveremo questo per dirvi non per
farmi bello per dire comunque il
lo sport è stato molto importante per me
fin da subito anche prima in incidente
sempre ho giocato a calcio giocato a
rugby
ho fatto nuoto pugilato e dopo
l'incidente
volevo trovare un modo per tornare a
fare sport
volevo provare quale sport riuscissi a
fare con la protesi e mi sono affacciata
l'atletica ho ricominciato a fare
pugilato ho ricominciato a calcetto
tornei di calcetto per quanto era
possibile però vedevo che non era mai il
massimo non riuscivo a dare tutto me
stesso finché un giorno è stato proposto
il sit in bolli che io non conoscevo e
la cosa che più mi ha stupito è che
entrare in palestra due entrambi in
palestra toglievi la protesi ti sedevi a
terra e giocavi senza bisogno di alcun
ausilio senza prove senza carrozzina e
senza nessun ausilio per chi non lo
sapesse sit in bolli era pallavolo
paralimpica che ha esattamente le stesse
regole della pallavolo e in italia è
nata solamente tre anni fa l'unica due
regole aggiuntive della pallavolo sono
che si può morara battuta avversaria e
al momento del tocco della palla
bisogna avere il gluteo a contatto con
il terreno
se no il fallo è il lifting che non ti
puoi alzare per quanto riguarda scala
nazionale come vedrete
sono tutti ragazzi con diverse
disabilità
comunque la rossa deve essere composto a
tutti a dodici atleti disabili con
eventuali eccezioni di minimi disabili
di due minimi disabili dove il minimo
disabile può essere per esempio per
capirci un atleta con una prassi interne
ginocchio all interno di anca mentre a
livello nazionale c'è il campionato
italiano che prevede la presenza di due
disabili in campo mentre gli altri
giocatori possa essere normodotati
mentre per quanto riguarda l'avventura
powerlifting lì è uno sport singolo di
squadra
io ho iniziato subito allenarmi con
la squadra nazionale perché quando ho
iniziato la squadra si stava formando ho
iniziato su perdere ancora nazionale e
questo questo momento è stato molto
importante della mia vita perché dalla
provincia di fermo dove io ero lo zoppo
si può dire ero con la protesi ero io
che avevo la protesi state dei giorni a
contatto con 20 disabili di tutta italia
di diverse età mi ha permesso di aprirmi
al mondo della sanità in una maniera
nuova che non ho mai pensato perché ho
visto incontrato persone che per 40 anni
cioè io facevo la festa in maschera con
la gamba di legno e ho conosciuto
persone che per 40 anni però mai tolto
la protesi per vergogna per timore per
non saprei
grazie al sit in volley e ai compagni è
riuscito a togliere la protesi
addirittura davanti a un pubblico con i
figli voleva giocare a pallavolo che
nello sport che amava con il figlio che
amava e con il sitting sei riuscito
le persone che aveva la pallavolo come
unico stimolo di vita gli sportivi
fissati poi non sta lì a giocare con il
sit in volley ci è tornato a vivere
e arrivato il momento del primo europeo
germania 1015 gli atleti di tutta europa
e lì è stata un'emozione grandissima ma
soprattutto è stato vedere come tutti
quegli atleti disabili vivevano con
tutta la normalità possibile con lo
staff la gente comunque girava intorno a
questo sport che era non armata di
persone normale ma in quella si sentiva
accettati se non c'era diversità non
c'era discriminazione non c'era eravamo
tutti uguali nei nostri versità per
capelli c'erano carrozzine c'erano prodi
sia a livello del ginocchio il livello
dell'anca le cose più disparate ma non
eravamo tutti uguali e quello è un altro
step che mi ha permesso di ampliare
molto il mio pensiero e questo è proprio
quello che io
ho trovato di valore nel sit in bolli
che non ho trovato un altro in altri
sport che ha sempre praticato la mia
vita è l'integrazione la
sensibilizzazione che si può avere
l'integrazione che ho detto con gli
staff ma soprattutto il livello di
squadre di club dove c'è un minimo di
due disabili e gli altri giocatori possa
essere normodotati il normodotato dopo i
primi due allenamenti tre allenamenti
vedono che le difficoltà sono le stesse
il gioco è lo stesso non c'è nessuna
differenza è capitato proprio nella mia
squadra
dopo i primi allenamenti il nostro
quello che adesso e allenatore
all'inizio da giocatore insieme a noi e
ci ha detto grazie grazie ragazzi perché
sono riuscito a vedere oltre quella
protesi
se io sono venuto il primo giorno ho
visto la pro di seto cavolo queste
persone ho avuto un problema cioè
problemi dopo due tre allenamenti lui
chiedeva noi dei consigli noi che
giocavamo per la nazionale che era occhi
allenati
quindi c'era anche quel rovescio della
medaglia dove noi era modo aiuto a loro
per riguardo la posizione migliore
questa puoi fare meglio così
io credo molto in questa
sensibilizzazione perché conoscendo
queste persone
questi atleti di tutta italia se ho
capito quello che può essere essere
giudicati solo perché si portano protesi
io per me e per altri non è un problema
cioè io so chi sono e non è la protesi e
ad armi o togliermi qualcosa ma molte
persone non ce l'hanno fatta
no non riesco a superare quegli sguardi
e per questo io credo molto la
sensibilizzazione non vi ho parlato
della squadra i siti poli di fermo tra
l'altro mi spesso trasportare perché mi
sono allenato con loro ma io voglia di
allenarmi di più perché con la nazionale
ce n'eravamo una volta una volta a
settimana
una volta al mese una volta ogni due
mesi quindi con grande impegno siamo
riusciti con la mia voi con la nostra
voglia di crescere siamo riusciti a
creare la prima squadra
dei siti in bolli nelle marche che la
scuola di pallavolo fermana dal dal 6
gennaio 2016
e questo è il gruppo che vi facevo
vedere prima che grazie all'impegno
siamo riusciti a formare un gruppo
fantastico e arrivare terzi al
campionato all'ultimo cambiato italiano
per club 16 squadre partecipanti è stata
un'emozione una bellissima emozione per
quanto riguarda quella sensibilizzazione
quel riuscire a far superare gli sguardi
e le stazioni è semplice far vivere a
stretto contatto le persone con la
protesi per fare in modo che non venga
più visto come qualcosa di diverso o di
strano ma solo quello che è ovvero una
silvio per camminare e con loro stiamo
cercando di fare molti più
manifestazioni possibile far conoscere
questo sport che secondo me sensibilizza
in maniera straordinaria ma soprattutto
corsi nelle scuole perché gli uomini e
le donne di domani saranno i ragazzi di
oggi quindi entrare in una scuola
durante l'ora di educazione fisica di
far giocare a pallavolo vedono cos'è una
protesi vedono cos'è un atleta che può
giocare a siti in buoni ma posso giocare
lì anche loro
il primo impatto sicuramente anzi sono
molto più attenti perché vedono qualcosa
di nuovo ma dopo la terza lezione mi
chiamavano per giocare con loro e quindi
già il lavoro il city il lavoro il city
embolia era fatto ira quei ragazzi hanno
sensibilizzati ormai la protesi non
vedevano più
vorrei concludere quello che c'era mia
idea disabilità poi spinge sul sit in
bolli perché quell'unione quell'affetto
che puoi avere quella dell'apertura
mentale perché nel corso della mia vita
sicuramente no
non sarei quello che sono oggi da solo
una fortuna avere una famiglia
fantastica che mi ha supportato in tutto
e per tutto ma mai lasciato mai da solo
allo stesso tempo soldi tutto quello che
potevano me hanno dato la vita ho avuto
degli amici speciali veramente speciali
qua che nel periodo in cui non avevo
ancora la protesi aveva ancora le ferite
aperte
mi dicevano da yes i ragazzi dove vado
con le stampelle da voi andate
tranquilli
loro venivano a prendermi mi portavano a
con certi versi spiaggia facendo in modo
che la mia condizione non fosse un
problema se certo non possa essere
facevano alzate persone se non si poteva
arrivare un posto in auto andavano
diceva dopo parlo io con la municipale
polizia e quindi non mi hanno lasciato
ma da solo e questo e fin da subito
questo dato a far a farmi capire che non
ero diverso perché non ho visto fin da
subito la limitazione nella mutazione
perché lì ero con loro
di nuovo con loro dopo l'incidente
divertirmi a vivere e la stesse cose che
ho trovato nel sitting dove non c'è non
avevo problemi con la prosa perché ero
io senza gamba senza prodi come il fondo
mia mi ha fatto
lì potevo tornare a uno sportivo anche
ad alti livelli in pieno senza alcuna
limitazione e infine sicuramente c'è il
mio modo di pensare il mio modo di
essere
che come ho detto prima non è speciale
io ce l'ho avuto fin da subito nel corso
del tempo ho avuto il piacere di
condividere con qualcuno qualcuno che
forse lines avevo bisogno di una spinta
di un aiuto e io sono stato contattato
da amici di amici di amici e ho detto
subito sì io vengo civitanova loro
piceno san benedetto vengono in vengo
assolutamente sì è sapere che quelle mie
poche parole con il mio poco tempo è
stato d'aiuto per loro per ritornare a
vivere torna a lavorare tornare per me è
stato come vincere la seconda volta
per questo per dirvi in tutto che
resilienza cioè perché per me ad oggi
non so come si sarebbe stata la mia vita
senza incidere ma ad oggi tra la mia
famiglia tra gli amici tra il mio modo
di essere di pensare che è il mio io ad
oggi mi sento che la vita mi ha dato
molto di più di quel piede che abbia
torto quando parlo con questi ragazzi
vado come ho fatto come con spirata
porto alcuni esempi e soprattutto il
primo era quando il primo giorno e
abbiamo protesi da bagno che sono andato
al mare con degli amici e abbiamo
postato una foto con tre uomini e una
gamba
oppure quando dopo il tremendo terremoto
le marche che io quando dormo senza
protesi non sarei potuto scappare in
qualsiasi modo che la mattina mi sono
svegliato a bordo del letto ho messo le
gambe nelle protesi e all'ato così è
sottomesso la didascalia anche stanotte
ero pronto a scappare a gambe levate
basta prendere consapevolezza di sé che
non ci sono limiti se non ci poniamo
perché tutti nella vita abbiamo dovuto
affrontare qualcosa di tragico che può
essere la perdita di un piede che può
essere la perdi una persona cara che può
essere una malattia un disagio qualsiasi
persona a un evento da sperare ma io
sono sicuro che superare quel limite
quell'evento traumatico si può e si deve
fare perché come ambrato il sit in la
vita è un gioco e ognuno di noi
ognuno di noi ha il proprio ruolo ai
propri infortuni nel corso della
carriera ma finché continuiamo a giocare
separati sarà difficile che vinciamo
quindi facciamo appunto come nel sitting
che ci togliamo le maschere ci togliamo
le protesi ci mettiamo in gioco tutti
insieme ognuno per i propri limiti per
fare in modo che questa che la
visibilità posso diventare dal limite
dalle opportunità
[Musica]
e scusate l'emozione
[Applauso]
[Musica]